Of course, this is all building
up to Shor's algorithm, which we'll see in the next lesson, which is an efficient quantum algorithm
for computing prime factorizations, but we still have some ground
to cover before we get there.
Next we're going to talk
about a mathematical framework through which we can measure the computational costs
of different algorithms,
including ones we've already talked about.
To be clear, we're going to be focusing very narrowly on circuits, which is just a small piece
of a much broader subject.
Let's start with a very high level view of an ordinary computation
from the previous lesson, meaning in particular that we're not thinking
about query problems,
we're thinking about
problems where the input is given explicitly as a binary string.
Like I said in the previous lesson, we could of course allow
other symbols if we chose to, but let's just keep things simple and stick with binary strings
for both the input and the output.
The computation itself could be modeled or described in a variety of ways such as with the Turing
machine model of computation,
Boolean circuits, quantum circuits, or programs written in
a language like Python or any other language of your choice.
Like I said a moment ago, we're gonna be focusing on
circuits, Boolean and quantum.
First, let's spend a little bit more time talking about the input and the output, which we're assuming are binary strings.
Using binary strings, we can encode many different sorts of
mathematical objects, such as numbers, vectors,
matrices, graphs,
descriptions of molecules, for instance, as well as lists of all of these objects and other ones as well.
As a very simple example, if we wanna encode non-negative
integers as binary strings, we can use binary notation.
Here in this table, you'll see the first 13
non-negative integers along with their binary
representations or encodings.
Here in the third column, you can see the length of
each of these encodings, which is just the total number of bits you need for the encoding,
and here's a simple formula that tells you exactly how many bits
are needed in general for any non-negative integer N.
Notice in particular that
the length of the encoding is generally much smaller
than the number itself.
It's logarithmic in the number.
RSA1024 for instance, has an encoding with length 1,024, but the number itself is of
course much larger than that.
This encoding scheme works
for non-negative integers, but if we want to handle
arbitrary integers, including negative ones, we
can simply tack on a sign bit.
We can also allow any number of leading zeros in these encodings if we want the encodings
to fill out a block of bits or a register of a fixed size
as long as it's big enough. Sometimes that's very convenient.
This isn't the only way to encode integers as strings of bits.
There are other ways that you could do it, but this is a pretty
standard way to do it.
For other sorts of objects that might form the inputs or the outputs to the computational
problems we're interested in, we can come up with
other encoding schemes.
For example, think about how
you might encode a vector or a graph as a binary string or think about how you might encode
two binary strings into
a single binary string using just the symbol zero and one without a space or any other symbol
to separate the two strings. There are certainly ways to
do these things, and in fact, we have a lot of freedom
as to exactly how we do it.
Often there won't be a single standard or universally agreed upon way to encode whatever thing we're talking
about as a binary string,
but that's okay, we can just pick one or we can invent a new one if we prefer.
From a purely formal viewpoint, we're thinking about computations as essentially mechanical transformations on strings of bits
and the specifics of whatever
encoding schemes we use are certainly important at some level.
But nevertheless, when we're designing and
analyzing algorithms, we usually don't worry all that much about the specifics of
the encoding schemes.
If you ask two different people to come up with a way to encode, say, molecules of a certain
type as binary strings,
you might expect them to come up with different ways to do it, but if these were reasonable people who knew what they were doing,
you could also reasonably expect that it would be a pretty
simple computational process to translate back and forth between the two encoding schemes,
most likely requiring a very
straightforward computation that would be quite easy compared to the actual computation
we're interested in.
The bottom line is that the details concerning the encoding schemes we use are often quite secondary and our focus is on the
algorithms themselves.
None of this is going to be an issue for this lesson, by the way. We're mainly gonna be focusing on problems that concern integers, which we'll assume are encoded in binary,
but it's something to be aware of.
In general, for whatever sort of problem we're talking about, the input length refers
to the number of bits we need to encode the input,
and we view the input length as being the size of the instance of whatever problem we're thinking about.
Now, let's consider
the computation itself, which is represented by the
blue rectangle in this figure.
The way that we'll measure
the cost of this computation is to count the number of elementary operations that it requires.
Intuitively speaking, an elementary operation is one involving a small fixed
number of bits or qubits
that can be performed quickly and easily like competing the and of
two bits, for instance.